Bangladesh es el major país del mundo…
si no te gusta estar solo.
Este país tiene la mitad de la población
de Estados Unidos pero concentrada en una
superficie equivalente al Estado de Illinois.
Es el país más densamente poblado del mundo.
También se trata de una de las economías
de más rápido crecimiento en los últimos
años.
En sólo 2 décadas, Bangladesh ha reducido
la pobreza a la mitad.
Hablamos del líder mundial en fabricación
textil, sólo superados por China.
De hecho, seguro que la camisa que lleváis
puesta ahora mismo o los pantalones están
fabricados en este país.
Pero esperad un momento porque todavía no
es momento de descorchar el champán!
Sí, Bangladesh crece muy rápido.
Pero todavía el 13% de su población vive
con menos de 2 dólares al día.
Esto son más de 20 millones de personas.
Si a esto le sumáis el hecho de que Bangladesh
es un país de mayoría musulmana, tienes
el caldo de cultivo perfecto para que ocurran
cosas como esta.
La actividad terrorista en Bangladesh se incrementó
en el 2016 pese a una caída a nivel global.
Pese a que Bangladesh tiene una Constitución
laica, hay regiones donde se lapida a las
mujeres adultas.
Y el 80% de la población cree que habría
que cambiar la legislación para que respete
los principios de la SHARIA.
Mientras tanto, pese al radicalismo de algunos
de sus ciudadanos, Bangladesh tiene una mujer
como primera ministra, SHEIKH HASINA, que,
como veremos, es la persona más poderosa
del país.
Y la líder de la oposición, KHALEDA ZIA,
es también una mujer.
En resumen, que el país vive un momento especialmente
tenso.
Especialmente si tenemos en cuenta que el
año que viene, el 2018, Bangladesh va a celebrar
unas nuevas elecciones.
Así que la pregunta es…
¿Puede Bangladesh convertirse en una república
islámica?
¿Por qué decimos que este país es una bomba
demográfica?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DOS HOMBRES Y UN DESTINO
En el año 1947, las colonias de la INDIA
se separan del Imperio Británico.
La parte donde el hinduismo era la religión
oficial se convirtieron en lo que ahora conocemos
como LA INDIA.
Las partes donde la población islámica era
la mayoritaria dieron lugar a otro país,
PAKISTÁN.
¡Podéis imaginaros el caos!
Millones de desplazados, violencia en las
calles y limpieza étnica de las minorías
por motivos religiosos.
Un absoluto desastre que incluso podemos ver
en este mapa.
En el medio la India y a izquierda y derecha,
la república de Pakistán, con un sistema
político basado en el Islam.
2.200 kilómetros separaban las dos partes
del nuevo Estado pakistaní.
Como podéis imaginar, tenía todas las papeletas
para no salir bien.
Más allá del Islam, estas dos partes no
tenían nada que ver entre ellas.
Ni siquiera hablaban el mismo idioma.
Los pakistaníes del Oeste despreciaban a
los del Este.
Y los del Este, los bengalíes, querían independizarse.
Así es como, en 1971, estalló la llamada
GUERRA DE LA LIBERACIÓN.
Se estima que entre 300.000 y 3 millones de
ciudadanos perdieron la vida.
Pero, como resultado, nació un nuevo país;
la República Popular de Bangladesh.
Y así es como este señor que veis en pantalla,
MUJIBUR RAHMAN o, más conocido como BANGABANDHU,
se convirtió en el primer presidente del
país.
Como os podéis imaginar, la nueva constitución
de este país era lo opuesto a la ley pakistaní.
Bangabandhu diseñó un sistema político
completamente laico.
Es más, se apuntó a la ideología de moda
en la época, el llamado SOCIALISMO ÁRABE,
que era un cocktail ideológico que combinaba
líderes autoritarios, economía centralizada
y laicismo.
¡Pero las cosas no fueron también para el
pobre BANGABANDHU!
4 años más tarde de hacerse con el poder,
toda su familia murió en un golpe de estado
organizado por los sectores pro pakistaníes
¿Toda su familia?
Bueno, en realidad, sus dos hijas sobrevivieron.
Entre ellas, Sheikh Hasina, la que hoy es
primera ministra.
Pero volvamos al golpe de estado.
Tras dos años de inestabilidad política
y de influencia del Tio Sam, el general ZIAUR
RAHMAN se puso al frente de un nuevo gobierno.
Y una de sus decisiones más controvertidas
fue la de concederle amnistía a los islamistas
que habían asesinado a Bangabandhu.
Y así es como nació la división ideológica
que ha marcado la vida política en Bangladesh.
Por un lado, tenemos a la familia y el partido
político del general Rahman, el Partido Nacional
Bangladesh o BNP por sus siglas.
Se trata de una coalición conservadora con
una fuerte presencia de partidos islámicos.
Por ejemplo, aquellos sectores que participaron
en el golpe de estado de 1975 se hicieron
miembros de esta coalición.
Por el otro lado tenemos al partido del difunto
BANGABANDHU, la llamada LIGA AWAMI que podríamos
decir que es socialista y laica.
El general Rahman gobernó durante 4 años
más.
Después, otro golpe de estado que llevó
a Bangladesh a una dictadura militar que se
prolongó hasta 1991.
A partir de ahí, la democracia volvió al
país.
Pero esperad un momento, porque la democracia
bangladeshí es de todo menos democrática.
DOS MUJERES Y UN DESTINO
Desde 1991, estos dos partidos políticos
han tenido a dos lideresas.
En el BNP tenemos a KHALEDA ZIA, la viuda
del general RAHMAN.
En la liga AWAMI tenemos a Sheikh Hasina,
la hija de BANGABANDHU.
Desde entonces, las elecciones han sido una
disputa entre estas dos mujeres, que se alternan
en el poder cada 5 años.
Ninguna de ellas consigue repetir el mandato.
Es más, las elecciones en Bangladesh son
de todo menos una fiesta de la democracia.
Normalmente, el partido que está en la oposición
en ese momento organiza protestas violentas
y huelgas que paralizan el país durante días.
Sin embargo, todo esto cambió en el año
2006.
En ese momento, la liga AWAMI de Sheikh Hasina
estaba disconforme con el proceso electoral.
Hasta el momento, todo igual.
Pero esta vez, el ejército trató de dar
un golpe de estado para poner algo de orden
en el país.
Algo parecido a lo que ocurrió en los 80.
Las elecciones se tuvieron que posponer por
2 años.
Y finalmente, HASINA se hizo con el gobierno
y aprendió una valiosa lección: lo importante
no es ganar unas elecciones sino mantener
el poder.
¿Recordáis que os decía que el general
RAHMAN concedió la amnistía a todos los
asesinos de BANGABANDHU en los 70?
Pues bien, su hija tenía buena memoria.
Así que utilizó esos recuerdos del pasado
para meter en la cárcel a todos esos islamistas
que habían participado en el golpe de estado
del 75 y que todavía podían hacerla sombra
política.
“Bangladesh ejecuta al líder del principal
partido islamista”
Por si esto fuera poco, Hasina rompió una
de las mayores tradiciones políticas en Bangladesh.
Normalmente, durante las épocas electorales,
el parlamento creaba un gobierno neutral para
garantizar un proceso electoral limpio.
Pero Hasina no estaba dispuesta a dejar el
poder.
Así que, en el año 2014, la oposición boicoteó
las elecciones.
Y, por supuesto, siendo la única candidata,
Hasina arrasó en los comicios con un 79%
del voto.
El partido del gobierno en Bangladesh gana
las elecciones de nuevo en una votación boicoteada
En otras palabras, a día de hoy, en 2017,
Hasina es el líder más fuerte en toda la
historia de Bangladesh.
Y esto no es ninguna broma si tenemos en cuenta
que este país tiene más de 160 millones
de habitantes.
Así que la pregunta es…
¿Queda alguien en este país que pueda enfrentarse
al poder de SHEIKH HASINA?
Y la respuesta es SÍ.
BOMBA DEMOGRÁFICA
Como decíamos al principio, en Bangladesh
hay más de 20 millones de personas que viven
en la pobreza extrema.
Son jóvenes y extremadamente religiosos.
En otras palabras, son el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para cualquier movimiento islamista
que se precie.
Y si, ya sé lo que estáis pensando…
“Fonseca!
¿No nos habías dicho que Bangladesh es una
de las economías de más rápido crecimiento
del mundo?”.
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Precisamente por eso, 20 millones de pobres
son un auténtico problema.
Vereis, si un día queréis montar vuestra
propia revolución populista, evitad ir a
un país que sea extremadamente pobre.
El mejor lugar para un movimiento radical
es, precisamente, un país que está creciendo
o que está saliendo de una crisis.
Esa es vuestra ventana de oportunidad.
En ese momento es cuando los ciudadanos más
desfavorecidos pueden empezar a envidiar a
aquellos que están mejorando su situación.
Por eso, esos 20 millones de pobres son un
nicho de mercado perfecto para la radicalización.
Y una amenaza para la estabilidad del país.
Y eso explica que los atentados terroristas
sean cada vez más frecuentes en Bangladesh
desde el año 2013.
Muchas de las víctimas son blogueros ateos
que difunden sus ideas por internet.
Pero la auténtica alarma llegó en 2016.
Atentado en Bangladesh: los pistoleros del
ISIS matan a 22 rehenes en un restaurante
de Dhaka.
Desde entonces, Sheikh Hasina ha intentado
frenar el terrorismo.
Sin embargo, como decía, en 2018 hay elecciones.
Y el gobierno quiere ganar apoyos entre los
sectores más religiosos de la población.
Eso explica que Hasina haya recibido con los
brazos abiertos esa inversión de 1000 millones
de dólares que venían de Arabia Saudita
para construir 560 mezquitas en el país.
A la vez, su gobierno ha frenado las leyes
que facilitaban que las mujeres pudieran cobrar
herencias o las que prohibían los matrimonios
con menores de edad.
¡Pero esto no es todo!
Un grupo de propagandista islámicos llamados
HEFAZAT-E-ISLAM envió al gobierno una agenda
con 13 sugerencias políticas.
Por ejemplo, querían que las enseñanzas
que se imparten en las escuelas islámicas
radicales tuvieran el mismo rango que un título
académico homologado.
Y, en contra de lo que cabría esperar, Sheikh
Hasina está llevando a cabo muchas de estas
reformas propuestas por los integristas.
Y no olvidéis que, al menos en teoría, el
partido de Hasina, la liga Awami, es el partido
que defiende el laicismo frente a las ideas
más tradicionalistas del BNP.
Así que la pregunta es…
¿Creéis que Bangladesh puede convertirse
en una república islámica de facto?
¿O simplemente es un juego político para
que Sheikh Hasina consolide su poder de cara
a las elecciones de 2018?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.